good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight people are totally
absorbed in the kyle rittenhouse trial
and you have to ask why is that why is
it so fascinating well part of the
reason it's just so interesting is
because the facts are so different from
what we've been told for more than a
year completely different and it's
shocking to compare reality against the
version of reality we've been force-fed
here's one example just days after
written house was first arrested that
was back in august of 2020 a
pro-censorship organization called
politifact published what it called a
fact check of the case
in a posting on its website politifact
claimed that kyle rittenhouse had
committed a crime by carrying a firearm
in the state of wisconsin here's the
quote it is against the law in wisconsin
for someone younger than 18 to possess a
dangerous weapon period
now you notice in that statement
complete unwavering certainty and this
is common for political fact which
issues opinions like their edicts from
god himself
they do this because the social media
companies reward it social media
companies use politifact's edicts as a
pretext to censor any speech online that
contradicts the official line of the
democratic party the so-called narrative
so politifact disagrees with what you're
posting then you are by definition
spreading misinformation and you must be
silenced that's how it works
so naturally other media organizations
echoed this position immediately kyle
rittenhouse 17 declared the milwaukee
journal sentinel was not old enough to
legally carry the assault style rifle he
had
end quote again just stating it as fact
and then the entire national media
followed suit and told us the same thing
the problem was it was a lie
in fact under wisconsin law which
apparently no one in any newsroom in
america had even bothered to check
17 year olds are allowed to carry rifles
as long as their barrels meet a minimum
length requirement and kyle
rittenhouse's rifle met that requirement
so no kyle rittenhouse did not violate
wisconsin's gun laws today even the
prosecution at the trial was forced to
admit that and so immediately the judge
dismissed the firearms charge
isn't legal
it is not a short barreled shotgun or a
short barreled rifle yes
either by barrel or by overall length
correct all right and then count to
six is dismissed
oh well that couldn't be clearer the
prosecution is admitting in open court
that it was legal he had not committed a
gun crime and that means that for more
than a year
big tech and its lackeys throughout our
media have spread misinformation about
kyle rittenhouse
well that's embarrassing what are they
going to say well they're not going to
admit it of course they're going to make
certain you don't learn about it just
minutes after the judge in the case
dismissed the gun charge youtube which
is owned by google censored the video
streams of several independent legal
experts who were commenting on the trial
in real time these were knowledgeable
attorneys many of whom were critical of
the obvious weaknesses in the
prosecution's case
now hundreds of people were watching
those streams at the moment they were
canceled
but concerned that americans might
conclude that kyle rittenhouse is
innocent youtube shut them down citing
quote policy violations in other words
god forbid people think for themselves
that's not not allowed anymore if you
want to know what's happening in your
world
you've got msnbc to tell you watch
here we have a 17 year old kid under age
said he bought an ar-15 because he
thought it was cool he drove across
state had his mother driving across
state lines he appointed himself a
militia member he goes around and he
ends up unloading what 60 rounds
amazing he's blonde now of all the
people you could find to comment on a
killing
it's interesting who they chose
but just listen to the words consider
how totally dishonest the summary you
just heard is virtually every word is a
lie
kyle rittenhouse wasn't a militia member
he was a lifeguard kyle rittenhouse did
not fire 60 rounds not even close to
that he was not underage as we just told
you he was in legal possession of his
gun
but most amazing is the claim which
you're hearing everywhere right now that
kyle rittenhouse is bad because he quote
drove across state lines
think about that for just a second
so the very same people who have told
you for years that borders are by
definition white supremacy now claim
it's some kind of moral offense for an
american citizen to enter a contiguous
state
they're making it sound like how written
have snuck into a foreign land under
cover of darkness to murder people
that's not quite what happened
take a look at this map this is kyle
rittenhouse's drive from his mother's
home in antioch illinois to kenosha
wisconsin it is
by the map says 21 our map program says
17 miles either way probably shorter
than your commute to work every morning
as kyle rittenhouse explained on the
stand last week when mob set fire to
kenosha he had every reason to want to
defend the city because his father lives
there
but you decided you needed to run
because of the fire on the duramax yes
why what was so urgent
it was a fire
why did you feel
that you
should go around
off the 59th street
car source property and put out
fires to make sure my community didn't
get burnt down and help
let me say your community you mean
kenosha yes
again you're from antioch you're not
living in kenosha at this time when this
all happens right my dad lives in
kenosha
how dare you put out fires
well my dad lives in kenosha
bet you didn't know that but you hadn't
heard it on cnn
nor of any of the people
hyperventilating about crossing state
lines explained why it's okay for the
blm rioters and the antifa creeps to
come from around the country to burn
kenosha down as many of them did
haven't even addressed that it's kind of
weird it wasn't a crime for them to
cross state lines
we could go on but if there's one thing
this trial has taught us it's how
completely dishonest and totally
misleading so many of the news accounts
of what kyle rittenhouse did have been
we've known for more than a year for
example how rittenhouse first
encountered convicted child rapist
joseph rosenbaum the first man he shot
there are multiple witnesses to that
most of it's on video actually joseph
rosenbaum had just been released from a
mental hospital and for some reason
decided to join the riot so first he lit
a fire
then he began to swing a chain like a
weapon
when he saw kyle rittenhouse he
threatened to kill kyle rittenhouse then
he chased rittenhouse and he full sprint
cornered him and then tried to snatch
his gun from his hands it was at that
point that rittenhouse fired who
wouldn't fire at that point
after shooting rosenbaum written house
tried to turn himself into police but he
couldn't because a mob howling for his
death chased him down a city street
one rider then knocked kyle rittenhouse
to the ground another smashed him in the
head with a skateboard and a third rider
drew a loaded pistol which he was not
allowed to have unlike kyle rittenhouse
and pointed it in kyle rittenhouse's
face
so at no point was kyle rittenhouse the
aggressor in the sequence of events
every move he made was defensive it's
not our interpretation of it that's what
came out from prosecutors and witnesses
in court
none of these facts
are disputed they all happened
so that's a very tough problem for the
prosecution with facts like those what
exactly do you say
what they said is really interesting so
today the prosecutor was left trying to
argue that convicted child rapist mental
patient joseph rosenbaum whose criminal
record you can read online and you
should just to get a sense of who
they're defending here that this guy had
threatened to murder kyle rittenhouse in
front of witnesses and yet
actually he was not a threat to cal
written house
and to prove it the prosecutor showed
this video watch
here is the defendant running in between
those parked cars slowing down and you
can see just how close or rather how far
away mr rosenbaum was when the defendant
shot him
i mean seriously you can see just how
close i mean sorry just how far away he
was right yeah so everyone whose eyes
were open could actually see it because
you just played the tape dumbo
apparently the prosecution is hoping the
jury had his eyes closed for that part
of the proceedings the whole thing is
ridiculous
and it got more absurd as the day
progressed
watch that prosecutor thomas binger
who's writing these names anyway explain
that if you take steps to defend
yourself you have by definition given up
your right to self-defense
they have to convince you that joseph
rosenbaum was going to take that gun and
use it on the defendant because they
know
you can't claim self-defense
against an unarmed man like this
you lose the right to self-defense when
you're the one who brought the gun
who's writing the rules here
let's just pause for a second
and go through what he said
there's no such thing as self-defense
against a man who has no gun really
well according to the federal
government's own statistics far more
people in this country are beaten to
death every year than are killed by
ar-15s
so that is a by definition ridiculous
claim
if an ex-con with a history of violent
crime informs you that he is going to
murder you and then tries to grab your
gun from your hands you are allowed to
respond in fact you have to respond
because it would be suicidal not to
obviously
but as a legal matter all that matters
here is whether kyle rittenhouse
reasonably believed that his life was in
danger
and of course he believed that why
wouldn't he you would believe that too
if you were him but it's the second part
of the prosecutor's lie that tells you
the most about how these people think
here's the quote
you lose the right to self-defense when
you're the one that brought the gun
really mr binger
so no one with a concealed carry permit
is allowed to defend himself
what's the point of having a gun if you
can't save your own life with it
well that's exactly what they're telling
you they're telling you don't have that
right you have no right to resist that's
the whole point of this whole proceeding
so the next time blm sweeps into your
town your neighborhood your house to
burn and loot and brandish weapons you
had better not try to protect yourself
or your family
try to protect yourself or your family
and we will charge you with murder and
while we're at it we'll have the
national media call you racist
in the court of public opinion they're
really arguing that white men especially
white men with a gun are allowed and
have the space to defend and protect a
country and a social order that keeps
them at the top and a country that they
stole from indigenous folks and built
with black people's labor the media is
participating and perpetuating this
charade because as far as i can tell the
only reason why any of this is allowed
is because of the whiteness of it all
so who emptied the gender studies
department and put them all on
television all at once
how destructive is this to the country
seriously putting crap like that on
television if you're wondering can they
racialize anything the answer is yes
they can
in this case there is to restate the
obvious no racial angle to the story
and if you're looking for proof consider
the fact that everybody involved in the
story
is the same color
and in fact in point of fact the only
bigot on the scene appears to have been
joseph rosenbaum the child rapist
for some reason and it's on video don't
take our word for it rosenbaum kept
screaming the n-word huh
and yet it's kyle rittenhouse who joe
biden accused of being a white
supremacist on the basis of no evidence
whatsoever and let's hope at some point
he gets sued for that
now they're calling the judge the same
thing too watch
let's hope for one o'clock i don't know
the
hope the asian food isn't coming it's
not isn't on one of those boats in long
long beach harbor
yes that was the judge making an
off-color joke about asian food during a
murder trial i want to ask you how
unusual
is the judge's conducts currently
well i think some of the things were way
out of line you know the comment about
the asian food for example
oh yeah that's that's racist
but really it's only racist if you're
exercising your right to self-defense or
if you're trying to conduct a fair trial
if you don't inject equity into the
trial and judge people on the basis of
their skin color rather than what they
actually did
if you dare to do that in this
post-equity country this post-blm nation
you are by definition a racist
so they won't admit to the public that
they lied to all of us for more than a
year this is all they have left you're a
racist
msnbc is by far the worst defender it's
shocking actually when you look at it
carefully but it's not the only offender
they're all doing this cnn's so-called
race and equity team can you even
imagine what those people are like in
any case they just published a piece
entitled that we're not making this up
quote judge in kyle rittenhouse trial
makes inappropriate asian food joke
inappropriate being the favored word of
people who want to slur
someone who want to attack someone's
reputation without explaining exactly
why inappropriate what does that mean
it's entirely subjective but according
to the piece as it gets more specific
the judge's joke about supply chains and
food
puts asians quote in the cross hairs of
microaggression as well as actual
physical violence
[Laughter]
so when you make a joke about chinese
takeout which by the way if you were a
bigot you probably wouldn't be eating in
the first place but if you dare to make
that joke
you're dangerous if you're the judge and
you haven't already unilaterally given
kyle rittenhouse the death penalty for
offending msnbc and joe scarborough then
you're a physical threat to asian people
these people are demented and they're
dangerous and that kind of talk degrades
the social fabric faster than everything
anything you can imagine
but if you're looking for true crazy
no one beats the race lady over at msnbc
earlier today the teenager accused of
murdering two men and wounding a third
in kenosha wisconsin last year took to
the stand in his own defense and the
circumstances are almost built for an
actual crt course the white now 18 year
old faces an almost entirely white jury
of his peers with the exception of one
black man dream with me paul
could any child of color young person of
color
ever ever ever ever
do that on a stand
and get away with it
you already know joy of course not this
is white privilege on steroids
again
there's no racial angle here
everybody's the same color
if a white guy shooting another white
guy is an example of racism maybe you
should tell us how
this is insane
just just so you know hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else